yeah when um when you
first lost your title to matt sarah that
was the first time
matt matt no no matt sarah yeah when you
lost your title to matt sarah and
you know and matt sarah stopped you you
know that was
was that like that had to be like the
most devastating
loss of your career right it was but i
learned something valuable
that allowed me to survive to carlos
gundit
what was that when i got hit by matsera
the first
punch he he he made me very dizzy
and i was so proud like pride it's a
good
thing but it could be a bad thing i was
so proud and i'm a very proud person so
i got
i got uh do you say in english right
wobble i got i got wobble
and instead of back off and say oh i'm
gonna go back to my sense
why did i go go back to my equilibrium
before re-attacking
i got wubble and i got so angry i was
like i can't believe this guy
because back in the day it was like five
to ten to one the
the odds i was like i can't believe i
get wobble by a guy like this you know
like like back in the day like
i was hey i was angry that i got wobble
i was proud guy first time i ever
happened in my life
so i wanted to give it back to him as
fast as i can
but maserati he hit very hard so i was i
was i i didn't have any equilibrium
i got a wubble with one shot then i
tried to jump back into a war with him
into a slugfest with him while i was
wobble and he wasn't so i got punched
like boom boom
boom then he started t off on me and
then i fall down and i tap out i know i
was completely
out i if i would have kept going i would
be like you know i
you know i had to stop and thanks god
the referee stopped but what happened
with carlos can did the same situation
i got kicked in the head then
then instead of telling oh i need to
give it back to him i fall on the ground
i said you know what yes i got caught
then relax now it's time to defense
catch up your breath catch up your
your senses bang bang bang i focus on my
defense my shield
close everything every opportunity has
to hurt me
and then i came back after so i stepped
into my my
uh my ego a little bit tried to accept
the fact that i got hit
relax and then i came back later that's
a little bit that's the experience that
i gained from that loss with material
that allowed me to survive
carlo's conduit oh interesting because
carlos can't do it dropped me with that
that that kick matzah the first time he
cut me
i wobble but i didn't drop like i was i
was on my feet
but i tried to get back right into a
slugfest with him instead of
of backing up try to use my footwork get
back to my senses and
that's what happened i got caught you
know sometimes you learn
during a loss and that's what happened
to me matt sarah by beating me he helped
me become a better martial artist you
know